Whoa.
Switch these at.
This is where we're doing it.
A little more column will sit on a wallet.
Uh,
hello everyone.
Welcome t toxic Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome the cast of Independence Day.
Resurgence.
We have bill Pullman.
We have Jessie usher,
we have Liam Hemsworth and we have Jeff Goldblum.
Hello.
Thank you all for being here.
Um,
smiley faces,
Smiley faces almost.
So happy.
I'm going to start with Jeff and bill.
What's it like to be back?
Yeah.
Oh,
you were looking at him.
Oh Man.
I can hear.
Ah,
fantastic.
Fantastic,
Mm hmm.
Because of the,
because of some of the new,
uh,
fantastic people in the cast,
besides,
um,
and science,
some of the returnees.
Uh,
there is,
Judd Hirsch in the latter category still plays my father.
Those are Charlotte to gardens.
Boy,
do you know that actress Charlotte Gainsbourg?
Do you know her?
Wonderful.
She started my love interest and,
uh,
the,
the theme,
the themes are more clear.
It seems to me than ever a strength in cooperative diversity.
Mm.
The foolishness of,
uh,
of an arms race and the futility of it.
And,
um,
and then the triumph of human ingenuity,
intelligence,
courage and science.
And it's all funny here and there,
or are you think of that?
That's why I'm happy to read that
Mk
drive safely.
See you later.
But thank you.
I'll be in the green room.
That's it.
See why I said let him go.
That's a torrent of information.
Sorry.
I apologize.
It googled the chip.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
it's been a really great thing to come back to this movie.
And,
uh,
I think having the new energy of another younger generation,
we have our children basically.
And as we know,
the future we borrow from our children.
And so,
uh,
the fight to preserve what we have and to continue as a race is important,
not just for ourselves,
but for the children.
Here they are,
I believe the children.
So
speaking of that,
I won't call them children,
but of the new comers to this,
um,
leave.
And Jessie,
did you get any valuable advice going into this whole adventure about stepping
into this
man?
It was,
you know,
a few times from,
from everyone.
I kind of just heard in their own way,
everyone kind of telling me to just buckle up because it's going to be,
you know,
a roller coaster.
It's going to be a whirlwind and just be ready for what's to come,
you know,
to try to understand what role and tells you when he's directing you as best as
you can and just go from there.
Yeah,
I mean it wasn't a thing specifically that I,
that I'm retired from these two individuals,
but,
uh,
just working with them every day was,
you know,
I didn't have a lot to do with bill.
We had one or two scenes together.
Um,
but I like him a lot.
He's a really great guy,
very nice guy.
And,
and I've been a huge fan of him ever since.
The first one and spice balls was also one of my favorite films.
Let's talk about it.
No,
but I,
I do love both of these people and,
and you know,
it's been a,
it's been a great time working with Jeff.
I had a lot of times with Jeff and uh,
yeah,
it's been,
it's been really fun.
I love you too.
Uh,
what can you tell us about your characters?
I play a fighter pilot and,
uh,
my character makes a bad decision early on in this story,
um,
and almost get someone killed.
And,
uh,
he's a,
he's very impulsive guy.
Someone who,
who he lost his parents in the first attack,
so he's an orphan and,
uh,
you know,
he's kind of why did his whole life for these islands to come back and,
and,
you know,
make a difference in this situation.
And,
um,
yeah,
he makes a bad decision and,
and gets his wings clipped and is sent to the moon as punishment.
Uh,
is,
is kind of forced to work as somewhat of a forklift driver,
but on the moon driving a moon tug,
which is not very exciting for a fighter pilot,
but that's what my character is doing at this point in the story.
Um,
and then a lot out a lot,
all that stuff happens off to that the aliens come back and,
you know,
a bunch of stuff happens.
Character has to rise to the situation.
Very well put.
Jesse,
what about you?
Can you,
uh,
yeah,
my character was introduced in the first film.
Um,
and then now he is 20 years older.
He is a Dylan Hiller,
the son of Steven Hiller and Jasmine,
which is played by will Smith and Vivica Fox.
Um,
so now,
you know,
my character has come up and he's sort of following in dad's footsteps.
He's also a fighter pilot.
Uh,
he had a very heated encounter with this young man right to my left.
Um,
you know,
and it creates a very interesting dynamic between these two characters that
Kinda just gets worked out throughout the story.
And you know,
like it says a whole lot happens,
the,
you know,
that
kind of stuff.
You know what I mean to that?
Yeah.
I'm really excited for the subtitles to have to translate what I was going to be
great.
They let me do it.
It's gonna be great.
Um,
so this movie,
the,
the events
of the first film are a huge spectacle and the events surrounding the film and
making the film seemed to be a huge spectacle as well.
And I'd imagine filmmaking itself has changed a lot in the last 20 years.
Um,
for those of you returning,
what was it like to sort of step,
did things change or was it just sort of like stepping into,
you know,
easy old role and we're rolling again or,
or was it a whole new experience?
I was expecting a lot more toys,
but uh,
and things that you would,
uh,
have never seen before.
But uh,
you know,
when we did the first one,
it was kind of old technology.
We made a lot of things happen with the Rowan's visual effects guide who was
from Germany and they were using a lot of old style,
uh,
all the fighting things were shot with a dye Arama that was on hydraulic lifts
that would move the desert up,
the pictures of the desert.
So a year and a fighter plane new,
you're not moving,
but the,
the whole big 90 feet is going up and down.
This time we go to the largest sound stage in North America in Albuquerque,
48,000 square feet.
And you go into this big huge room and it's just an empty room with blue walls
and blue ceiling and so that they could put it all in later.
And so suddenly the coolest thing you see is a Humvee jeep that's coming up the
tarmac to a fragment of a plane.
That's just the door.
Cause that's all you need.
They're going to do the rest later.
So in a way it's a little less but a lot,
a lot more.
Once you say Jeff,
a little less for us,
but later on it looks great for us.
It's not at all right.
Then you go,
you walk around or you were watching the monitors and they have the instant
ability to put in all the background and they're feeding all the plate shots in
there and suddenly you realize,
oh wait.
And they'd asked me to duck my head is because there is a 70 foot airplane above
my head,
you know?
So in a way it's more intimate I found because it's a lot more like theater when
somebody comes walking up to you,
there's not a lot of information visually around them.
It's just the person.
And for this movie,
I think,
uh,
everybody thinks their own movies,
the most special movie,
but for us that were part of the first one,
it was like a family experience.
There's a lot of soul in the movie that's about popcorn movie.
And I think when Rowan went to cast the next generation,
he looked for people that were not only good actors but had some soul.
So,
you know,
it's a great thing for the story,
I think to be having that kind of intimacy in the way that you relate to each
other.
And so the,
all the special effects actually that could put in later,
you know,
don't,
don't get it in a way of making a human story.
Well put.
Well I stopped the show.
Yeah.
All right.
We're done.
Great.
Thanks guys.
Um,
I mean none of you are sort of strangers to that special effects,
big blockbuster world,
but was there,
you know,
you've,
you've on it a little bit.
Was there anything for you guys that you were surprised about filming this,
that you were like,
I did not think it was going to be this either taxing or physically demanding,
you know,
um,
these guys are vets.
This was like my first time dealing with a lot of what we did on,
you know,
on this set.
And I think the day that we kind of went,
I don't want to give away too much,
but you know,
we,
we go to an outer worldly place and it's,
it's almost like a jungle gym that's been covered in like blue paint in like
blue tape and stuff.
And the activities that took place in that area was way more exhausting than I
thought.
It was.
Like I felt like I was training to be a seal or like,
I dunno,
something,
it was crazy.
Like,
and then of course Roldan wants to do 500 takes.
I was in the best shape of my life by the time we finished that scene.
Man,
he knows what I'm talking about.
Roland likes to do a lot of takes.
Um,
I,
uh,
you know,
he's,
I love Roland.
He's easy,
great guy,
really nice guy.
And,
and someone who I've been a big fan on for a long time,
but um,
does more takes than anyone I've worked with,
which is a good,
is a great thing because it,
it,
you know,
for,
for actors,
you get this huge playground too.
Just trying to think you want,
you know,
and you get the time and,
and you know the takes to do it again and then because you get the freedom to do
that,
you know,
you really have just,
you can try anything.
And now that was what,
that's what's great about rolling.
He really gives you the freedom,
you know,
and a lot of the time you do five or six takes and he doesn't actually come up
and really give you any direction.
So you kind of like,
we're doing another one.
Alright,
cool.
Any notes?
I just do another one.
All right.
I'll just do it a completely different way,
I guess.
You know,
you kind of give your own direction,
but you know,
every now and then if he,
if he feels like there's something that's missing,
he'll come up and tell you something.
But he really gives the act of the,
the,
the freedom to try what they want to do and explore different ideas.
And,
and that's that,
that,
that was what,
what was great about this process or sometimes you remember that day that we
were,
we have a scene,
I don't want to give it away,
but you've,
you've talked about it.
We're on the,
we go to the moon together,
the Earth's moon.
We go to the moon and we're on the moon.
In the sound stage.
We're pretending to be on the moon in these,
in these very expensive,
uh,
as it turns out,
the moonshine go suits.
You know,
we're in Windsor.
You've,
we've seen it.
If you've seen the trailer,
you see us in those suits.
And so we were doing these takes.
That's right.
And we would work sometimes 16,
17 hour day is not the,
finally,
it's a peevish to complain.
But you know,
I did,
can feel strenuous sometimes,
but I like to get a direction and I would ask you for direction.
Yes,
I'll hammer.
He would,
he would just say,
yeah,
do another one.
And I would say,
Hey,
you tell me before we do another one,
what should I do on this one?
I'll do anything you say.
I directed Jeff Goldbloom and has felt it was very good at acting.
So if you think he's a really good actor in this,
particularly better than anything else,
you've seen him.
It's because me,
he pulled that performance out of me.
I did it.
Yeah,
he's a,
yeah.
I said,
uh,
Sharlto gardens borrow it gives in the thing.
He says,
turn around and you're supposed to do something.
Find gesture to maybe Jeff.
He said,
uh,
yeah,
this one turned around and go,
hm.
I like that.
I said,
okay,
watch this.
Let's go.
Rolling.
I'm ready.
Right.
And a action.
Okay.
And we did.
Then we did a few more and then Roland came back.
He said,
well,
what was that one where you did that?
No,
know.
Yeah,
no,
I didn't bust him.
And I didn't say,
well that was his idea.
Yeah,
no,
it seems like you guys had a lot of fun going into this.
Uh,
did,
did you guys do anything in sort of the prep leading up to starting filming to
sort of get to know each other?
Or is it just sort of let's dive in.
We're all in this together.
You know,
we did,
we,
we didn't have a lot of time before this that we shot together.
I mean,
it's,
every project is different and sometimes you have a lot of time to rehearse
things and get to know people.
This wasn't one of those,
we kind of jumped right into it.
Yeah,
I think.
Um,
but,
but you know,
I,
like I said,
I didn't,
I didn't have a lot to do with,
with bill in this film,
but I still love him just as much.
I don't want to exclude him in any way,
but,
but I worked with Jeff a lot and um,
yeah,
no,
we had a great time together.
I was just thrilled to,
to watch someone like Jeff Goldblum and,
and see how he works and how he does things.
Just charged your,
your fantastic.
He's really fantastic.
And those are not just show business now let me embarrass you.
But uh,
yeah.
Fantastic.
So gifted and sweet as you can tell.
You know,
which I Johnny,
lovely man.
Yeah.
Bill my card.
I'm going to assume that term limits still apply in the universe.
This takes place in so that you are no longer president.
But uh,
you know when you're well,
you know one in calls,
Bill Clinton,
Ex President Bill Clinton.
This is true,
but does this mean zero?
That's true.
Oh,
I'm still president Whitmore yes to the world.
But I,
uh,
I,
I think all of us,
we're really glad that the only pre shooting thing that I did was with the
writers and Roland and we all did that.
It was very unusual for a big blockbuster movie to him.
But it's because Rowan's position in the industry that he's got a lot of
control.
So he invites us all because he is willing,
he has no fear.
So he is no actor's going to say something that's going to disrupt the best
movie that he wants to make.
So we all went in there and he asked us,
what do you think this character is or what would juice you up?
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
and I thought I had,
uh,
all of us feel like we got a chance to kind of take the characters in a
different way.
So even though we're coming back,
you know,
for me,
I was the one that had the most intense contact with aliens in the first one in
the we mind melded,
which I know you do that at Google a lot,
but it was hard on me with an alien.
And,
uh,
it ended up being a little bit like PTSD where you function for awhile when
you're back and then the symptoms start to come in.
By the time 20 years later,
I'm an embarrassment and shuttled away and taken care of by my daughter.
And so my thing is that I've,
you know,
I get accused of being paranoid in it at,
because I view him having premonitions they're coming back.
And these people don't think so.
It was an interesting character and very different than the first one.
Jeff,
did your character with somebody very immersed in technology and sort of at the
forefront of it at the time,
do you think?
Or can you tell us if the events of it either led him to engage more in trying
to,
you know,
keep a lookout or just kind of abandoned ship and be like,
I don't want to deal with this anymore.
I don't want to,
you know,
you get to live in a hut in the desert.
Very interesting question.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
and I'm glad you mentioned that about those writers.
I,
that,
that's right.
That is a nice word.
Was a lovely part of this.
Felt,
felt very creative and independent film me or something or very trusting and,
uh,
we were able to make a contribution.
We met with,
I had long meetings with Nick Wright and James A.
Woods,
the other James A.
but they're both actors also when they act parts in the movie,
you'll see them in the movie.
But anyway,
they had,
those were wonderful sessions with the writers are my character.
Uh,
um,
was,
was a,
is asked to and takes on the task of,
uh,
being a,
in a leadership position,
uh,
for the earth space defense in case they come back.
Uh,
and so technology is,
is what I know and a,
and I have a lot to do with rebuilding,
uh,
over these 20 years,
you know,
much was destroyed,
many people were lost,
but also in building a weaponry,
uh,
and war strategies that might anticipate what we could be faced with if and when
they come back.
So,
uh,
even though you're right,
it's not my,
it's not what I imagined myself David Levinson doing.
I was a person not of self glory or spotlight or a,
um,
or war.
I think I,
my character probably would have been environmental.
Uh,
they're very green in one way or another and uh,
anti a war.
But the events happened,
has happened 20 years ago and here I am in this position and that kind of tees
up and sets up what's about to happen when it's probably no surprise.
They do come back.
Spoiler alert.
Yeah.
So Jesse,
Jesse,
Jessie,
Atlanta.
I'm curious if Jesse,
your character is sort of exists in the first film and you know,
it's not quite a developed character but,
but were you at all intimidated by the opportunity to kind of create a part of
this legacy?
I mean,
the film is huge.
We were having another one in,
it's like,
people want it to another one.
We're getting it other way.
It took a little while,
but we're getting it.
We move.
Uh,
what,
uh,
you know,
how did you feel going into it?
Ah,
it's static.
You know,
I wasn't necessarily intimidated.
Um,
the way that,
you know,
these guys are so supportive of us,
like coming in and being a part of this film,
you know,
and,
and that was more uplifting and it,
it gave us,
you know,
a sense of comfortability and,
we felt like we could bring something new in the aisle.
You know,
we're very open to any ideas that we had and Roland and the writers and
everybody's,
well you know,
like they were saying before that we had these sessions would be sit down and
just talk to them and they would listen to us.
Which you know,
it just makes you feel like okay you guys have this thing that's on this,
you know its pedestal and you're trusting my opinion with it.
So it makes you feel,
you know,
comfortable,
you feel good.
So it wasn't necessarily intimidating at all.
It was,
it was just more of a,
you know,
the appreciation to be
a part of.
Yeah.
I mean I look,
I coming in to the hunger games for instance,
right,
where you have a huge fan base,
which is the equivalent of something like this.
We've already got a huge fan base.
As an actor I don't feel like you worry about the sorts of things.
Like is it going to be a good movie?
I mean you,
you focused on the work you have to do there and,
and you know,
hopefully you have a great director,
someone who can lead the whole cast in the right direction.
And I think that takes a lot of the pressure off and you don't,
you don't so much think about those sort of things.
You know,
you get to set and you're doing your job and,
and for me,
I,
I love that part of this world.
I love making movies.
I love the whole collaboration of people coming together to make something
special.
And,
and like I said,
hopefully you have a great leader that,
that,
that you know,
can steer you in the right direction and a,
and you don't need to worry about the,
the sort of,
you know,
the grand a picture of it all.
Would it be fair to say it's more about taking a,
a great role and not worrying about you because you already know what's going to
be a great movie like picking based on it.
Yeah.
I think also we're going to take audience questions in a second.
If anyone wants to line up Mike's back there.
Um,
but my,
my question to you is if,
if aliens actually came to the universe we live in,
uh,
what,
what would your reaction be?
Nowhere near what Dylan's reaction was.
I mean,
he was ready to go.
A Jesse personally,
I would need to think about it.
You know,
I need to evaluate the situation.
I need to see what's happening.
I need to know if they're bigger than I am.
And then you know,
we can go from there.
Okay.
We like that to Google evaluating the
part about these things.
You can't just go in.
I don't know what they know.
That's true.
Anybody else prepared for extraterrestrial contact or
shoot?
Now ask questions later.
Smart way to go.
Yeah.
I think we'll take our first audience question.
All right.
This is for everyone.
Uh,
if you can work at Google,
what team would you want to work on?
What are the options?
I mean,
I don't know.
Search,
maths,
chrome,
g-mail,
android,
self driving cars.
I been,
I don't know if this is a rival thing and I might be saying the wrong thing.
Right.
I've been to the other side of town.
Where the face,
is it the Facebook?
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
I got a great outdoor situation.
I don't know if it's the same here.
I haven't explored this area,
but I would love to do any job if,
if it's like Facebook.
This talk is over.
Thanks so much for joining.
We have outdoor space too.
I don't know what position,
what position do you take part in?
Uh,
I'm a software engineer on Youtube.
That sounds complicated.
How do you,
do you guys have all the really cool cafes and stuff that Facebook has sleep.
You got that?
I'm there.
I'll do anything.
I'll be a Janet.
I'll do anything you want.
Yeah,
so they do use youtube.
Youtube is all you guys,
right?
Call us.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well I go on the youtube alive.
I love it.
That's one of the one,
one of my preferred learning tools.
Ooh.
One to another and then this suggests that and I'm lost in there for awhile.
Yeah,
I love it.
We are always delighted to hear user story.
Okay.
So,
uh,
Jeff,
this one's actually for you.
Yes ma'am.
So speaking of Youtube,
have you seen the youtube clips of you would making ads where like they slow you
down really?
And you just sound really weird.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Yes,
I have.
And it said Drunk Jeff Goldblum right.
Goals.
What do you think of those?
I like him.
That's perfect.
So it's not hard cause I'm like drunk anyway.
I'm not,
I'm straight,
I'm straight as an arrow.
I don't,
I don't drink.
But we did this thing and I was looking on TV yesterday and saw as played back
on the NFL.
We were outside doing something and I don't know what got into me.
I was listening to the music and I had the music going on in me and I looked at
it,
I thought you goofball what?
You look entirely dry.
And sure enough people said,
is he drunk?
Oh yeah,
he's on something.
So it doesn't take much a post production to make me look like an idiot,
you know?
And then,
yes.
So then stemming off of that,
you do like,
you play a lot of really like weird characters like Tim and Eric and Portlandia.
Have you ever played one that like just made you feel uncomfortable like that it
was just too strange?
Nope.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Define.
Yeah,
like why you're like,
why?
Well,
I mean,
I gave him a big invitation.
It's going to take some time.
Yeah.
I mean I,
if something is,
if somebody says,
oh yeah,
you're strange and we're looking for a strange guy and here's a part and we want
you to be strange or do another take and make it really strange and weird.
It might depending on the situation or the care,
but mostly I'm like,
I don't think you've understood my,
at least what I enjoy about my own,
imagined what I do.
I wouldn't say that I'm strange or weird,
but now that I'm tear myself talking,
I'm probably,
I'm not exactly regular either.
Emma,
you're never mind.
You're unique.
You don't do that.
You do things in it different way and it's unique and it comes from the most
loving place you do.
It's true.
It's a great guy.
He's a really great,
great Greg.
Thank you.
Very,
very.
Hi,
this is for all of you.
If you were in a superhero movie,
what character or superpower would you want to have?
Don't know.
I used to say teleportation like instantly,
but I don't know,
a lot of the new superhero movies kind of make superpowers that I never really
thought were that cool.
Seemed way cooler these days.
So I don't,
I don't know that,
I mean,
I think the time in my life when I felt most like a superhero,
and I'd like to get back to that time was when you're younger is when you have
most of your levitation dreams and all of you are probably still having them,
but it's a phenomena that you lose it.
But one of the greatest thing isn't a very fast action thing,
but it's when you just start floating up through the staircase of your house and
then you've float through the windows and you float into the tree that's next
year house.
And uh,
I come on,
you've all
out of the house.
Well,
it's a very unsexy thing to float,
but a,
and I don't know whether I'd make the marvel superheroes as a floater,
but,
uh,
that's what I'd like to do.
The floater.
A floating man.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
my questions for Jeff.
so growing up I watched Jurassic Park and had lots of nightmares.
Um,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry.
So I just wanted to know,
like what are your thoughts on the new drastic world and would doctor Malcolm
ever go back?
I didn't see them too.
I haven't seen the new,
I,
I know,
I'm waiting to see.
I had a baby.
We had,
you know,
we had a,
we've been working on the movies 60 to 79 and then in the middle of it on
Independence Day,
July 4th,
I had my first child,
Maddie's baby on independence,
independence day,
and Forrester.
I think it just came naturally.
We,
so just yesterday was the fourth,
right?
Where he was just seventh month,
the birthday in any case.
What was I saying?
Oh yeah.
So no,
I haven't seen it.
I want to see it.
Is it good?
You'll love it.
I want to go see it.
Yeah,
let's not,
let's talk about the fact that you had your baby on independence day.
I seen sign.
What about that?
I know that the chances of that actually happened.
Well,
I'd never been through it before noon and my wife Emily and the doctor said,
Oh,
here's the due date,
July 4th and it was the drug but make no mistake and that's kind of a couple of
weeks here or there either side.
That's what usually happens.
But sure enough,
she,
you know,
midnight happened on the third turning into the fourth and she said,
I think,
uh,
I think something's happening.
And I had made sure and the production very generously made sure I was home,
you know,
back from Albuquerque and that I had a.
Dot.
And she,
she started to do the thing
and he slipped.
He popped out.
Yeah.
There are about six that morning,
make a speech at it.
Was it about this day and
this day
you will come.
You will.
We'll make it out there.
Hey guys,
this question is also for Jeff Mine
on behalf of a couple of friends,
Steve and Gary,
that they asked the question,
if you could get the whole cast of Buckaroo Banzai back together,
would there be part two and perhaps another dimension?
Thank you.
Well,
eight dimensions was the one in that.
I have a fondness for that movie and I know there's other,
some devoted followers to it.
They had some ideas about it.
It,
you know,
in any way.
Yes,
I would.
Peter Weller,
uh,
I've stayed in touch with,
he started the band that I'm in.
I'm going to,
I haven't,
I'm gonna Bet Jesus.
What happened?
I'm getting too excited.
I'm in a band called the Mildred Snitzer orchestra.
If you come down to la where it will Rockwell every Wednesday,
but he started that band.
We started it together anyway.
Uh,
yeah,
if we got together,
maybe we'd make another one of those.
You like that you liked that movie?
You've never seen it?
Oh,
this is just Steven Gary talking there.
Okay.
I will tell him how I tell him.
All right.
Hey guys,
I'm gonna bring us back to independence day
as much as I love you Jeff Goldbloom.
And this question actually comes from a big fan of yours.
She has a shirt with your face on it that's also shirtless switch.
It's very interesting.
Uh,
but my question for each of you is,
um,
if you were stranded on an alien planet,
which of your cast mates would you bring with you and why?
From this moving.
Okay,
wait,
I have a followup question.
Is it,
is it the character or is it like that the real,
like the real person.
Okay.
Like present time.
Cause Liam as an injured back.
So like that I'm a Hamam disabled.
Disabled,
right.
They're changing so much.
I want to,
I wanted to tell everyone before I sat down and then if I move a lot,
it's because of my back.
I've got a pretty serious back injury right now and that's why I'm moving.
We don't need to talk about it.
Let's move on.
It's boring.
You're rugged.
You were surfing extreme.
He's an extreme sportsmen and you were doing extreme.
I hurt my back.
I'm like a,
an old man,
the sample back.
It's okay.
Uh,
I don't,
don't bring me to that,
to that planet because I'm not gonna do anything.
But you could bring Brent spiner then,
you know,
be a good kind of smart guy to get a beer of your bank,
right person to bring,
cause he's really,
really smart.
Can probably figure out.
And it does your high desert plain or view on your planet like an Alien Planet,
alien planets,
uncharted territory.
We really like aliens here apparently.
I don't know Brent.
Brent spiner would be a great person at Bragg.
Um,
well yeah,
I mean if there were scientific challenges and environmental challenges,
you'd want somebody that could help you last a day or two.
But if there aren't,
then we're just talking about the dirty game,
you know,
a who would you rather then?
It's,
and I can't play that.
I'm not allowed to play it.
Our conversation.
No.
Who would you rather be?
Desert Island.
I can think of something.
I'm not saying.
Yeah.
Hi.
Uh,
so independence day has a,
I guess a strong Scifi component.
There've been a lot of Scifi movies coming out lately.
Uh,
so just wondering if sort of anything in the film jumped out as,
as you,
uh,
in terms of being like creative or novel around how like the aliens are,
the alien technology or just the human relationship with the aliens were
portrayed.
Very interesting question,
Huh?
Oh,
his birthday.
I think it is.
That's really interesting.
Yeah.
What's original and fresh about the A,
yeah,
it's a very wide open,
uh,
issue and probably we can't,
so there are some interesting,
fresh,
unexpected,
the things about how we relate to them about them,
about stuff we find out about who they were 20 years ago.
We get revelations about what they were up to,
who they were,
where they're from,
but we proud.
That's all we can say.
You probably shouldn't tell you.
You'll see the movie and you'll see.
You'll see.
All right.
Very intriguing.
I was going to see it anyway,
but now I'm really cool.
Hell yeah.
Finger.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it's an interesting question.
I think we were just talking about it.
I think one could construe a Cody and far from the visitation that we find out
things about them.
And then these current visitors that shed light on our own.
Yeah.
Situation and identities,
uh,
and uh,
ignorances and things we need to work on.
What do you think about that?
Almost like a young Ian Dream,
you know,
I can say no more.
Yeah.
Actually that's a good segue to my question.
I was just wondering,
um,
if while you're filming or after the movie's been made,
if I'm Independence Day permeates into your dreams or aliens infiltrate your
sleep time.
No,
I think,
um,
for me when we were doing the film,
we spent so many hours doing the film that the sleep is like,
you know,
it's so deep.
We're making up on the hours that we lost so that I don't think anything is
infiltrating my dreams at this point is just,
it's just out cold.
And I don't think I've had a dream about an alien since we,
since we've left,
we saw enough of that.
I would say the complete opposite.
I have horrific nightmares often.
Um,
and during this filming I had terrible nightmares,
particularly about you and I running from aliens.
I swear to God,
I'm not kidding.
I honestly,
I have,
I have night terrors and it's something that I should probably see a doctor
about.
But I get sleep paralysis.
I wake up and I can't breathe.
Sometimes man,
Jeff are running from aliens.
It's all kinds of stuff in my dreams.
I think I have serious problems and I should say someone about it.
That's the honest truth.
Oh,
those aren't problems.
No.
We know about dreams that they give you a chance.
Some people think to live out and siphoned off and uh,
you know,
hidden dogs in the basement,
psychologically.
So they come to some kind of conscious light and the opportunities to see how
they're useful,
you know?
Yeah.
I think,
cause we've been talking about how sometimes,
you know,
these,
these movies are about empirical,
you know,
chronological gathering information.
It's,
you know,
we're sometimes in,
dream mythology is to culture,
like dreams are to the psyche and there's certain things that get healed and are
exposed in dreams that we can't deal with and empirically.
So some of the best stuff I think in science fiction is stuff that really tricks
that,
you know,
to that level of,
uh,
of dream awareness so that,
you know,
probably everybody in a dream is some version of yourself.
And there's different aspects of aliens that are,
are aspects of ourselves.
And sometimes you can only see that in an instant,
in a dream.
And you wake up and you had some knowledge,
you can't quite remember what that was.
And I hope this movie kind of has that with a little bit.
Uh,
we,
we were saying that might be good and result.
I like to be scared by movies.
I liked the feeling of,
you know,
can't figure it out.
It's,
it's night.
And then I dream.
I dream a lot.
I have recurring things of all kinds.
I'm being chased.
I'm be there,
I'd have bad bedroom.
We'll take our last two questions from the audience.
First of all,
thank you so much for coming out here to Google and by the way,
having those days.
So I'm taking as a birthday present,
right?
Happy Birthday.
I said this is for Jeff and Phil and over the years had you been presented with
any scripts for a type of,
and if so,
like what made this one special to make you want to be a part of it and if not,
then again,
what?
What made it special for you to want to move forward with it?
Right.
W we weren't presented with sequels to this alternative sequels to this movie
before this script,
do you mean,
is that what you're asking?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
no,
no.
This is the first time they said,
you know,
we've been working on it.
Or Dean Devlin is the other creator.
They've been cooking it up and they said we,
I think we got something a couple of years ago now.
I think we got something that we couldn't show you talk to you about and that
this was the first one,
you know,
and I was thrilled about yet and
them and everything.
Yeah,
there was,
there's uh,
you know,
this was always a personal project for Roland,
uh,
he's done a lot of big movies and uh,
but on this one we all noticed and many people who work around him said he's
working in a different level on this movie.
This is really personal for him.
And that's partly why the long hours and the many takes,
there was some monkey inside him.
That really one end he did that.
He waited 20 years because not because they couldn't make a deal or something
like that.
He never really felt comfortable that he had the script right.
In about four years ago,
he thought he almost had it right.
And so we all got,
you know,
I got to call a,
the bands getting back together again and we're going to going on the road,
but it didn't.
And then reverse engines and then he cracked it with a,
about a year ago in November.
And I'm in about a three week writing session with these two writers.
And so that's what started us back on that.
We're going to do it.
I think we'll take our last audience question.
Um,
so bell,
I just wanted to let you know that I really liked you in sleepless in Seattle,
but I'm also,
I guess as the last question,
um,
what was the turning point in each of your careers that made you decide to
continue with acting and not something else
wants to go first on that one,
I once had a conversation with Harrison Ford,
uh,
sitting on set with him and I said,
did you ever have a point in your career where you questioned what you were
doing and why you were doing it?
And he looked at me like I was a complete stupid idiot.
It's like,
no,
this is you guys,
you guys limb.
This is the best job on the planet.
No,
I never had that.
I'm like,
absolutely.
Me Neither.
I'm just kidding.
I'm just gossiping.
A great job.
It is for me.
Um,
I moved from the East Coast to Los Angeles to pursue acting.
And then,
I guess right around the time that I finished high school and started going to
college,
I started studying culinary arts and I like,
I fell in love.
I mean I was already in love with culinary arts,
but like being like in the kitchen all the time with like these incredible
chefs,
like guys from France and all over the place.
And like,
I started to love that more than I'm the acting world.
And I kind of got drawn into that.
And
I think I even had a conversation like with the agents and my parents and
everybody and I'm like,
all right guys,
you know,
we had a good run but I think this is what I want to do.
And um,
they pulled back a lot and they kind of convinced me to just,
you know,
take the selective ones,
like maybe like,
you know,
read something.
If you really like it,
if you feel like it can work and if it works with your school schedule,
then do the audition or,
you know,
try to do the project.
And I booked a show and the show was incredible.
A lot of phones called level up on cartoon network.
And I mean we just had like the best time and every time I would enroll to go
back to school,
we would get picked up for like something else.
It started as a movie for a movie for television and then on to a series.
So I had to drop out I think three or four semesters in a row.
And then I kinda just went to the chefs at the school and I said,
look,
you know,
you guys know this is what I want to do.
I was already taking internships and all kinds of stuff.
And they're like,
yeah,
yeah.
So we made this agreement,
like when it slows down,
I will go back and like finish the culinary degree and like opened the
restaurant I've always wanted and it just hasn't slowed down yet to that point.
Um,
but you know,
that was turning 24 this year.
That was seven years ago.
It's seven,
something like that.
Um,
you know,
being involved in this industry and getting to do what we do,
like I said,
it's the best job in the world and it only takes a little bit of time for you to
realize that,
you know,
it's,
it's hard not to love.
So I'm very happy with where I am now.
Yeah.
Anybody else?
Yeah,
if I could show you.
Yes.
The um,
I,
you know,
I admire,
uh,
you know,
doubt and,
uh,
the,
the uh,
asking,
you know,
you're so smart and wise asking constantly along the way,
is this the best use of,
you know,
life?
Oh,
this precious opportunity.
Is this the best use of my energy?
Um,
me,
I had this idea,
I wanted to be an actor since I was in like fifth grade.
I saw children's theater that I did not,
I got this idea and I just stuck with it.
And by the time I was in high school,
I was obsessed and it would go,
we'd write on the shower,
I take a shower every morning and in high school and the shower door would get
steaming.
It was a glass shower.
And I would write every day,
I please God,
let me be an actor and then I would erase it.
So nobody saw.
It was just a secret of mine and for many years and then a thing.
And then the luckily,
and I'm still grateful that it's,
you know,
so I was very passionate about it here.
I'm still thrilled I'm doing it,
but I,
I still all the time do try to get clear about what it was that,
what was that seed and what is it that I'm trying to accomplish?
Is that the best use of my life and time,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I think it's,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
it is,
there are times just feels very important to,
uh,
to do.
And you don't know exactly why sometimes.
I think there's,
it's,
I think there has to be,
especially if you're starting out and you don't have a lot easy breaks,
uh,
you gotta tell yourself,
you know,
is this what I have to do to be healthy?
Is this is what I have to do to stay alive and engaged in the world.
And,
uh,
even if I don't get to do everything,
what do I do?
Uh,
will,
I,
will I be all right just going at it,
trying to pursue it.
And I think of that because,
you know,
it's so interesting,
you're a child of someone who's a also acted.
And so,
you know,
my son has just gotten into it and he had a lucky,
lucky thing happen where he got cast in a pilot,
uh,
just the end the last year and now he's going to be,
he did his first movie rule last month,
who has seen with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
And I'm looking at him and wondering does he have it that,
you know,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
in Macbeth thesis,
I'm not without ambition,
but without the illness that should attend it.
And you have to have a little illness to attend.
I think,
cause it's a lot of reasons where,
I mean we're saying it's a great thing when you get the jobs,
but there's many months where you aren't doing the job and you're wondering why
the other guy got the job and are vaguely,
you know.
And so I think that got that kind of thing is always a question.
But I think the fact that I think I don't really have a choice.
That's what makes me keep interested in pursuing it.
I think it's lovely.
I mean you guys have said,
I have to think applies to anything that somebody is passionate about,
be it software engineering or acting.
And if you guys bring half as much hilarity and insightfulness to this movie as
you did this conversation,
I think we're all going to have an amazing time.
Uh,
so thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you.